abrechnung mit parteifreunden afg chef
heute überrascht die eigenen leute auf
dem parteitag mit scharfer kritik
zweifel an neuen maßnahmen die skepsis
wächst ob die gerade erst verschärften
corona regeln in deutschland ausreichen
und überflieger in kuusamo weltmeister
markus eisenbichler gewinnt auch das
zweite weltcup-springen dieser saison
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers in einen guten abend
und willkommen bei uns heute am samstag
der sport in der sendung nachher mit
kristin otto in 15 minuten genannt die
größte oppositionspartei im bundestag
lädt zum parteitag
eigentlich soll es um ein rentenkonzept
der afg gehen doch dann hält parteichef
jörg merten eine rede die mehr eine
abrechnung ist mit dem rechtsaußen teil
seiner eigenen partei und auch mit fdp
fraktionschef alexander gauland die afd
trifft sich in kalkar haben niederrhein
mitten in der pandemie mit 600
delegierten und rund 100 gästen vor ort
das ganze muss aber unter auflagen
stattfinden maske tragen zum beispiel
auch am platz dagegen hatte die afg
geklagt allerdings ohne erfolg
es ist dann inhaltlich ein parteitag mit
überraschungen christiane hübscher
berichtet die übergroße mehrheit der fdp
delegierten hält sich an die hygiene
auflagen für den aufreger des tages
sorgt parteivorsitzender jörg merten der
in seiner rede mit der afg scharf
abrechnet das kann und darf so
keinesfalls weiter geht entweder wir
kriegen hier die kurve und zwar sehr
entschlossen und sehr bald oder wir
werden da als parteien keine zukunft die
ganz ganz schwere see geraten und
gegebenenfalls scheitern
ohne ihn beim namen zu nennen kannten
den fraktionsvorsitzenden bauland ab es
sei nicht klug von einer corona diktatur
zu sprechen die keine sein und
kritisiert hab das andocken von teilen
der afg an die querdenker bewegung
bauland reagiert getroffen es war
abrechnung mitteilen ohne dass sozusagen
genau definiert wurde
was denn völlig falsch ist und es ist
nicht alles völlig falsch auch der
gesamte bundesvorstand scheint gespalten
nach der rede
morgen bekommt für seine kampfansage im
saal viel applaus aber auch
ich finde es wichtig dass in unserer
partei auch bestimmte sachen
ausgesprochen werden die einigen leuten
nicht passen
und das hat er gemacht und das ist
richtig da gibt es einen dissens in der
partei es gibt den dissens auch in den
personen der bundessprecher das sehe ich
auch und die partei wird sich sicherlich
irgendwann auch entscheiden müssen was
der richtige weg ist mehr bauernhöfe als
jörg merten steckt jedenfalls in dem
leitantrag zur renten und sozialpolitik
den die ard am abend mit großer mehrheit
verabschiedet nach jahrelangem streit
die einigung ohne radikale forderungen
flexiblen renteneintritt entlastung für
familien und auch beamte sollen nach dem
willen der partei in die gesetzliche
rente einzahlen
vor der halle demonstrierten derweil
etwa 500 menschen im
nordrhein-westfälischen kalkar gegen den
bundesparteitag der afd
da müssen noch mal sprechen mit nicole
dick machen sie ist vor ort in kall
cargo namen nicole das war eine
generalabrechnung was wollte der afg
chef denn mit dieser rede bezwecken
es ist wohl nicht übertrieben zu sagen
erstens die partei retten man sei jetzt
an einem punkt sagte morton in seiner
rede an dem wörtlich alles kaputt gehen
könne die fds mit ausbruch der korona
krise in den umfragen im frühjahr
eingebrochen und dümpelt seitdem bei
acht bis zehn prozent und das könnte
noch weniger werden denn zweiter der afg
droht die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz teile der parteispitze
suchen den schulterschluss mit
querdenken den protest auf der straße
gegen die korona maßnahmen der opfern
rechtsextremisten organisiert wird und
nun warnten davor dass sich die afg noch
weiter radikalisiert dann bleibt
natürlich die große frage kann sich
heute nach diesem auftritt mit seiner
linie auch tatsächlich durchsetzen in
der hfg
ganz klar ist das nicht denn er steht an
diesem wochenende hier nicht zur wahl es
gab bucher nach seiner rede aber auch
beifall und wenn man mit den delegierten
hier spricht man sagen die einen das
musste jetzt endlich mal so klar
thematisiert werden und die anderen
nennen treter spalterisch corona ist das
neue thema an dem sich der alte streit
in dieser partei entzündet aber der ist
seit heute noch tiefer denn dass ein
parteivorsitzender offen die eigenen
leute den eigenen fraktionschef im
bundestag alexander gauland vor einer so
großen bühne angreift das ist ein
bemerkenswerter vorgang und das könnten
leuten viel übernehmen denn nun geht man
offen verstritten in einen super job
ein bemerkenswerter tag in kalkar bei
der afg nicole herzlichen dank für diese
analyse heute abend unser nächstes thema
die zahl der korona neuinfektionen in
deutschland bleibt auf einem hohen
niveau
aktuell meldet das robert-koch-institut
21 1695 positiv getestete binnen 24
stunden das sind knapp 1300 fälle
weniger als vergangenen samstag am oder
mit dem virus sind an einem tag weitere
379 menschen gestorben
es gibt also keine explosionsartige
zunahme mehr aber wirklich deutlich
sinken die zahlen eben auch nicht
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
sagte der zeitung die welt wir haben
drei bis vier lange winter monate vor
uns er hält es für möglich dass die
beschränkungen des öffentlichen lebens
bis ins frühjahr verlängert werden
reichen also die derzeitigen regeln und
passen sie wirklich das sind fragen die
sich ganz besonders in aktuellen corona
hotspots stellen wie in passau volker
dutschek
439 37 eine zahl die nach einer
notbremse verlangt fast 440 passauer pro
100000 einwohner haben sich in einer
woche mit dem virus infizieren
der zweithöchste wert bundesweit hinter
dem thüringischen landkreis
hildburghausen
die stadt passau verschärft ab heute die
maßnahmen wer raus geht muss einen guten
grund haben arztbesuch einkaufen oder
arbeiten dazu dauer masken pflicht
wechsel unterricht ab klasse 7
schnelltests für altenheim besucher
skepsis in der fußgängerzone ob das
schon reicht die ansteckungsrate in den
griff zu kriegen hat wirklich den
eindruck das liegt einfach daran dass
man zeigen möchte man will irgendwas
unternehmen aber ich glaube nicht dass
das jetzt wirklich was bringt ich werde
ehrlich gesagt ich persönlich gesagt für
einen zweiwöchigen harten locker und
gewesen anfang november aber dass das
was wir jetzt machen glaube ich nicht
dass das zum ziel führt skepsis
gegenüber dem von bund und ländern in
aussicht gestellten kroner lockerungen
zur weihnachtszeit und silvester
die kritik wird lauter auch in der union
fraktionschef brinkhaus sagt für
weihnachten und silvester ist es sehr
ärgert sich schon jetzt lockerungen zu
versprechen
gerade für silvester ist das äußerst
ambitioniert wir dürfen nicht durch eine
ausgelassene partynacht einreißen was
zwei monate lang hart erarbeitet wurde
dollar nun party machen wie im letzten
jahr viele biologen sind strikt dagegen
wenn der fallzahlen nicht weiter nach
unten sinken und die lockerungen in dem
maße ausgenutzt werden von der
bevölkerung wie sie möglich sind rechne
ich damit dass wir im januar wieder
deutlich steigende zahlen haben werden
in passau sind die geschäfte weiter
geöffnet die inhaber haben davon nicht
viel
die kunden blieben heute weitgehend aus
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf allen
unseren nachbarn der besonders unter der
pandemie leidet und es nun geschafft hat
mit wirklich harten beschränkungen das
corona virus erst einmal auszubremsen
und das ist belgien ende oktober erzählt
das vergleichsweise kleine land bis zu
20.000 neuinfektionen ein dramatischer
hand stieg die regierung zieht die
notbremse
alle geschäfte bis auf supermärkte
müssen schließen home office wird
verpflichtend und kontakte dafür es nur
noch zu einer person außerhalb des
eigenen haushalts geben
die folge die infektionszahlen gehen
zurück aktuell auf gut 2.000 wirklich
locker will belgien jetzt aber auf
keinen fall glück wallbott richtige
weihnachtsfreude kommt nicht auf
angesichts von fast 600.000 corona
infizierten und 16.000 todesopfern
zwar gehen die zahlen erstmals seit
wochen zurück doch die massnahmen
bleiben streng große feiern zu
weihnachten oder silvester sind nicht
möglich maximal ein besucher pro
haushalt ist erlaubt bei single
haushalten zwei ausgangssperre ab
mitternacht und kein feuerwerk
wir wurden ja schon auf ein sehr
schwieriges weihnachtsfest vorbereitet
das sind natürlich schwerer aber ich
glaube notwendige entscheidung das muss
gemacht werden um eine dritte welle zu
verhindern die wäre eine katastrophe
gelockert wird immerhin beim
einzelhandel ab dienstag dürfen läden
wieder öffnen unter strengen auflagen
nur einzelkunden einer pro zehn
quadratmeter verkaufsfläche gastronomie
friseure kinos sportstätten bleiben
geschlossen
die situation sei immer noch zu kritisch
sagte der regierungschef
das letzte wort und das letzte was wir
jetzt tun sollten ist weihnachten und
silvester in gerade mal vier tagen alles
das aufs spiel setzen was wir in den
letzten vier wochen erreicht haben die
drastischen maßnahmen zeigen wirkung
trotzdem meldet das elf millionen
einwohner zählende belgien noch 245 neue
cupid krankenhaus patienten täglich
intensivstationen sind überfüllt
kliniken arbeiten an der
belastungsgrenze
wir spüren jedenfalls hier noch nichts
von einem rückgang der wm-norm über
weitergehende lockerungen wollen die
behörden erst im neuen jahr beraten und
so viel in dieser sendung zunächst zur
corona pandemie jetzt unser nächstes
thema im iran könnte der anschlag auf
den atomwissenschaftler mans series ag
für eine riskante eskalation sorgen
präsident hassan rohan ii machte die usa
und israel für den tod von farrah der
verantwortlich der als schlüsselfigur
des iranischen atom
auf dem programms galt johanni warnte
aber vor unüberlegten racheakten
die reformer im iran hoffen dass die usa
unter dem künftigen präsidenten joe
biden zum atom deal zurückkehren
überall in frankreich haben tausende
menschen gegen polizeigewalt und ein
geplantes sogenanntes sicherheitsgesetz
demonstriert die demonstranten
befürchten dass die pressefreiheit
dadurch eingeschränkt wird das gesetz
stellt bestimmte videoaufnahmen von
polizeieinsätzen unter strafe einige
gewaltbereite demonstranten warfen
steine und feuerwerkskörper
die polizei setzte tränengas ein
angefacht wird der protest außerdem von
neuen videos die brutale polizeigewalt
zeigen und in frankreich für empörung
sorgt die appelle internationaler
politiker an äthiopiens regierung haben
nicht geholfen
jetzt hat die armee in der region t3
offenbar die regionalhauptstadt l'aquila
eingenommen
äthiopiens ministerpräsident und
friedens nobelpreisträger ahmed will die
dort regierende volksbefreiungsfront
entmachten weil sie ihn nicht anerkennt
hunderte menschen sind in dem konflikt
bereits getötet worden
tausende sind auf der flucht tim kröger
die militäroffensive im norden
äthiopiens ist offenbar in eine
entscheidende phase getreten
mehrere quellen berichten dass die
kreishauptstadt mit kelle von schweren
geschossen getroffen wurde mittlerweile
meldet die äthiopische regierung sogar
die volle kontrolle über die stadt
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht
die offensive auf mitchell war vom
premierminister ahmed nach einem 72
stunden ultimatum bereits am donnerstag
angekündigt worden
die letzte kriegsoperationen für uns nun
ist michael einzunehmen und das
kriminelle team dort festzusetzen
versuche mit premierminister ahmed den
friedensnobelpreisträger von 2009 10
eine verhandlungslösung zu finden waren
zuvor gescheitert
es geht um den konflikt zwischen der
zentralregierung und der
volksbefreiungsfront integra tplf die
äthiopien lange dominierte nach dem
amtsantritt von abi aber an einfluss
verloren
hunderte wenn nicht tausende sollen
bereits gestorben sein
zehntausende sind bereits vor den
kämpfen in das nachbarland sudan
geflüchtet
das größte hindernis momentan für die
humanitäre arbeit ist der zugang auch
deswegen haben wir den äthiopischen
premierminister und seine regierung
beharrlich gebeten uns zugang zu
garantieren
125 millionen euro seien notwendig um
die flüchtlinge allein in sudan in den
kommenden sechs monaten zu versorgen und
damit in der sendung zurück nach
deutschland die berliner spd hat sich
neu aufgestellt bundesfamilienministerin
franziska giffey und fraktionschef reizt
alle übernehmen den vorsitz des
landesverbandes gefallen würde 2021 auch
als spitzenkandidatin antreten bei der
wahl zum berliner abgeordnetenhaus
allerdings steht sie unter druck weil
ihre doktorarbeit auf mögliche plagiate
überprüft wird
der bisherige parteichef und berlins
regierender bürgermeister michael müller
trat auf dem digitalen parteitag nicht
mehr an
er kandidiert im nächsten jahr für den
bundestag
in nürnberg wäre jetzt eigentlich
christkindlesmarkt der vorweihnachtliche
wohlfühl treffe millionen und der duft
von glühwein gewürzen fränkischer
bratwurst läge über der altstadt nichts
davon in diesem jahr
wir wissen warum wie die nürnberger
damit umgehen dass corona hinein strich
durch die rechnung macht das zeigt jetzt
sala schulen gemüsestände stadt
weihnachts glanz in der nürnberger
innenstadt steht heute nur der
wochenmarkt in normalen jahren lockt der
budenzauber des christkindlmarktes rund
zwei millionen besucher aus aller welt
an
undenkbar in corona zeiten die stadt
schätzt den wirtschaftlichen schaden
durch die absage auf rund 180 millionen
euro
wirtschaftlich ist es natürlich für uns
eine ganz große katastrophe weil
natürlich das schon im dezember für
viele marktkaufleute für die
schausteller für den einzelhandel und
viele natürlich auch gastronomie aber
auch hotellerie
die haben mit dem geschäft gerechnet und
es fällt dieses jahr komplett aus
besonders hart trifft es schausteller
und marktkaufleute wie jürgen ullrich
das ganze jahr über hat der
weihnachtsschmuck produziert nun bleibt
er auf einem großteil der ware sitzen
dieses jahr haben alle bestellt aber
niemand hat sie abgenommen und wir
sitzen jetzt drauf und ich gott sei dank
muss ich sagen sie wird mit kaputt ich
kann es aufheben
aber sie ist halt bezahlt ist von uns
vorgestreckt andere verkaufen ihre
artikel nun übers internet und
verschicken ein bisschen weihnachtsmarkt
feeling für zuhause und auch das
christkindl ist dieses jahr
ausschließlich online zu bewundern
ich glaube dass dieses jahr einfach
alles anders ist dass wir uns auf andere
sachen einstellen müssen und dass man
einfach weihnachten mehr zu sich nach
hause holen
und das ist ja auch nicht schlecht das
irgendwie ein paar vereinzelte boden
gibt es aber auch in diesem jahr corona
freundlich verteilt über die ganze stadt
so jetzt hoffen wir auf gute nachrichten
in dieser sendung geht es dir das wäre
dein job die hab ich war ein toller
wintersporttag im eiskanal von sigulda
zum beispiel beim zweierbob-weltcup dort
setzte sich beim dreifach triumph der
deutschen frauen laura erneute mit
leonie viebig durch vor den zeitgleichen
duo ist yaman kam mark und calic strack
bei den herren raste mit bahnrekord
francesco friedrich mit torsten marx zum
dritten saisonsieg
auch die rodler staaten erfolgreich in
die weltcup saison der dreimalige
olympiasieger felix loch gewinnt in
innsbruck igls zweiter wird johannes
ludwig lochs 40 der weltcupsieg und sein
erster seit februar 2009 10 der
überragende athlet der jungen skisprung
saison heißt markus eisenbichler mit
sprüngen auf 146 und 141 meter fliegt
der bayer im finnischen ruka der
konkurrenz davon und feiert im zweiten
springen den zweiten sieg starker
saisonauftakt der deutschen biathleten
im finnischen kontiolahti denise
herrmann wird im einzel mit einem
schießfehler zweite nur 0,8 sekunden
hinter der fehlerfreien italienerin
dorothea wierer 20 von 20 scheiben
trifft auch newcomer stola holme gerät
aus norwegen und siegt vor landsmann
johannes b erik lesser läuft auch dank
starker schlussrunde auf platz drei die
rollstuhlbasketball nationalmannschaft
der frauen wurde
vom deutschen behindertensportverband
zur para mannschaft des jahrzehnts
gekürt die paralympics siegerinnen
erhielten die ehrung vor der sprint
staffel der para leichtathleten und dem
gobal team der männer und zur fußball
bundesliga borussia dortmund ist der
große verlierer des neunten spieltages
denn der erste fc köln gewinnt erstmalig
seit knapp 30 jahren im stadion des bvb
die geißböcke stoppen gleichzeitig ihre
negativ serie von 18 spielen ohne sieg 2
1 in dortmund bayern münchen gewinnt in
stuttgart drei zu eins und leipzig mit 2
2 1 gegen bielefeld max kruse sichert
union berlin den ausgleich zum 3 3 gegen
frankfurt
augsburg freiburg 1 1 im abendspiel
empfängt gladbach schalke
gestern gewann wolfsburg mit 5 zu 3 das
nordderby gegen bremen morgen noch zwei
spiele an der tabellenspitze hinter den
bayern nun leipzig vor dortmund und
leverkusen kann morgen auch noch am bvb
vorbeiziehen
wolfsburg und berlin tauschen hinter
augsburg rückt frankfurt in die obere
hälfte stuttgart und bremen runter auf
zehn und elf am tabellen ende
köln nach dem ersten sieg vorläufig auf
15 im keller kann sich aber noch einiges
verschieben und mehr dazu im aktuellen
sportstudio in dem die khedira brüder zu
gast sind
wir sind gespannt danke christian kalt
aber oft sonnig so geht es morgen für
die meisten durch den tag wir sind beim
wetter sie haben es gemerkt erst rtl ii
hat gleich alles ganz genau 22 uhr 45
ist zeit für das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka morgen um 7
freuen wir uns wieder auf sie für heute
danke fürs zuschauen und ihnen allen
einen sehr angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weiterhin bringt
tief tanja hier im osten europas kalte
luft aus dem nordosten und wenn sie mal
genau hinschauen hier richtung neiße
da gibt es sogar etwas schnee wir
schauen aber erst einmal in die nacht
und da bildet sich wieder nebel vor
allem im süden und auch entlang der elbe
nach norden hin
und sie müssen verbreitet mit glätte
rechnen vor allem in den nebelgebieten
denn die temperaturen sinken verbreitet
unter die null-grad-marke minus ein grad
im nordwesten deutschlands - 6 im
südosten ja und mit drei grad an der
ostsee ist es am mildesten morgen im
tagesverlauf lichtet sich der nebel
allmählich dann gibt gibt es häufig
sonnenschein vor allem im westen aber
auch nach süden im osten kommen dichtere
wolken auf ja und hier an der neiße und
im erzgebirge kann es etwas schneien die
temperaturen dazu minus 1 grad an den
alpen und 6 grad an der oder
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
montag wird es größtenteils trocken sei
nur an der nordsee da regnet es etwas
höchste temperaturen minus 1 bis 6 grad
oder am dienstag kommt regen aus dem
nordwesten weiter ins landesinnere bis
in den süden und geht dort in schnee
über vorsicht es wird klappt auf den
straßen ein schöner abend